nunca olvidaré el 27 de enero de 1945
las tropas soviéticas concretaron la
liberación de auschwitz birkenau uno de
los mayores campos de exterminio nazi
hacia el final de la segunda guerra
mundial unas 6 millones de personas la
mayoría judíos fueron asesinadas
atrozmente cada año la unesco lidera las
celebraciones del día internacional en
memoria del holocausto rinde tributo a
las víctimas y ratifica su compromiso de
luchar contra el antisemitismo el
racismo y contra todas las formas de
intolerancia y de violencia contra la
diversidad humana precisamente este año
las organizaciones judías denuncian el
riesgo de banalización del holocausto y
del aumento globales de incidentes
contra judíos en 2021 que calificaron
como el año más antisemita de la última
década
hoy en directo américa nos unimos al
ejercicio de memoria y para ello la
conversación es con marcos peckel el
director de la comunidad judía de
colombia e invitado habitual de france
24 marco gracias por estar con nosotros
una vez más y porque el 2021 fue el año
más antisemita según la comunidad judía
pues no según la comunidad judía en
todos los primeros buenos días gracias
por la invitación a frente 4 son
estadísticas puras y duras de incidentes
antisemitas que han ocurrido alrededor
del planeta
desde ataques como el que vivimos en la
sinagoga en texas hace apenas unas
semanas hasta ataques a personas judías
en las calles grafitis
ataques a cementerios donde son
desesperadas las tumbas y en las redes
sociales obviamente una gran cantidad de
ataques de incidentes de expresiones
antisemitas desde el 2001 un año que es
muy complicado en ese tema en 2021 sí y
precisamente aún dando más en ese tema
el antisemitismo la xenofobia el racismo
son los males que aún hoy tenemos que
seguir combatiendo y todos los días lo
vemos en las noticias que nos frena como
sociedad y cuál es la lucha de ustedes
para superar estos bloqueos tan
dolorosos y que tanto nos cuestan
bueno el primero que todo
y preservación de la memoria como usted
bien lo dijo al comienzo de la nota el
27 de enero la asamblea general declaró
en el año 2005 ese día como el día de
recordación del tema del holocausto pero
recordemos que también hace exactamente
una semana la asamblea grande las
cervecerías pasó una resolución por
consenso en la cual se condena la
negación y la trivialización del
holocausto y si esa resolución tiene que
darse es porque hay un problema real de
ya sea organizaciones personas o países
miembros de naciones finas como irán que
promueven la negación del holocausto de
ahí la importancia de preservar la
memoria de las víctimas que lo que
nosotros estamos haciendo hoy y con
vacilantes y primó todos los medios
existen leyes existen formas de hacerlo
y de esa manera
ha sido nuestro estilo casi por 2000
años y lo seguiremos haciendo bueno y
entonces como evitamos que caer en esa
trivialización del holocausto que están
haciendo ustedes qué acciones anualmente
se realizan
pues más allá de los eventos que se
realizan hoy la educación es la clave de
la educación sobre lo que ocurre con la
gravedad recordemos que tras el
holocausto que dejó a seis millones de
judíos como víctimas más miembros de
otras minorías justita nos opositores
políticos
s
educación son lo que ocurrió el
holocausto fue lo que dio origen al
derecho internacional humanitario los
juicios de núremberg que se llevan a
cabo después de la guerra de ser
juzgados criminales nazis
significaron que incluso en la guerra no
todo se vale - el genocidio o el
asesinato indiscriminado de civiles como
ocurrió y de ahí en adelante toca seguir
educando y toca seguir haciéndolo por
generaciones para preservar la memoria
para aprender las lecciones y para
seguir adelante como la unidad humanidad
mejor para todos pues lo invito a que
rápidamente hagamos ese ejercicio aquí
en directo américa cuántas vidas se
perdieron cuántos se salvaron cómo
sucedieron estas atrocidades de no salgo
de cifras de marcos para tener más
contexto para nuestros televidentes
bueno
en lo que tiene que ver con el pueblo
semilla de judíos murieron un millón y
medio de niños en la fecha del 27 enero
es simbólica porque fue la liberación
como hicieron usted el campo de
exterminio de adscribir que no por las
tropas soviéticas madrid se convirtió en
sinónimo de
lo bajo que puede caer la humanidad
de esos seis millones de judíos murieron
tres y medio millón de judíos de polonia
y esos seis millones constituían dos
tercios de la población judía de europa
de nueve millones en la conferencia de
avance que se conmemoran 80 años que se
llevó a cabo el 20 de enero de 1942 el
objetivo era asesinar a 11 millones de
judíos europeos por lo tanto esas cifras
son casi que incomprensibles pero cada
una de esas 6 millones es una víctima es
miembro de una familia es dolor es un
nombre y un apellido que hay que
recordar y a partir de estos recuerdos
que tenemos y de estos momentos
históricos pues viene un reasentamiento
de judíos en el mundo toda una diáspora
de la que ustedes ve por ejemplo es
heredero como ve usted el día de hoy
hacia atrás es el reasentamiento judío
en el monte
bueno creo que a los judíos debemos un
soplo más trineo que movernos de un lado
a otro mis abuelos maternos fueron esas
dos de esos seis millones de víctimas
en el campo de concentración auschwitz
pero américa latina nos apoyó termos
comunidad estudios en américa latina de
más en américa del norte
en nuestra vida tiene además de vivir la
vida como cualquier ciudad del país en
el cual habitamos es mantener y
preservar la memoria mantener y
preservar nuestra identidad como judíos
podemos somos judíos somos colombianos
de fe judíos somos orgullosos de nuestra
nacionalidad colombiana y orgullosos de
nuestra identidad judía y así es como
vivimos en las distintas comunidades de
médicos alrededor del planeta y ya para
finalizar marcos usted es profesor
universitario en varias universidades de
colombia como si fuéramos sus alumnos
cuál es la tarea que tenemos para
continuar con este legado de remembranza
y sobre todo de no repetición
pues la educación de el holocausto es un
tema
y si éramos nosotros que se diera en
todos los ámbitos educativos formales e
informales en las escuelas públicas en
las escuelas privadas en las
universidades online no es una enseñanza
que nunca se detiene y creo que es
obligación porque el holocausto del
problema obviamente para el pueblo judío
pero su prueba para la humanidad
constituye el mayor crimen convertido en
la humanidad contra uno
objetivo específico contra el pueblo
judío un exterminio
industrializado de eso es necesario
aprenderlo para evitar que vuelva a
ocurrir para que las nuevas generaciones
ya no que eran sobrevivientes vivos sino
muy pocos los han pasado de 80 años y
por lo tanto cuando ya no haya más
sobrevivientes queda en nosotros la
obligación de preservar la memoria de lo
que ocurrió